está todo en juego y sobre todo que
Argentina no salga este mundial porque
de perder pues ya los de Messi tendrían
que tomar el avión de regreso para
Buenos Aires el día de mañana ese es un
enfrentamiento muy candente no solamente
va a hacerlo en el campo de juego sino
también en las gradas porque se van
lanzando pullas los hinchas de ambos
equipos en las calles de doha en el
metro por donde quiera que estén ahí
están los mexicanos diciendo Canta y no
llores a los hinchas argentinos estos
dos equipos ya en la historia de los
mundiales se han enfrentado en tres
ocasiones pero queda tal vez en la mente
las ocasiones de 2006 y 2010 porque en
ambas ocasiones Pues fue Argentina la
que sacó a México del uso mundiales Así
que es un partido que también tiene un
aire de revancha eh para este equipo
mexicano vamos a ver entonces esta noche
qué ocurre en el estadio de lucidez en
donde debe haber unas 80.000 personas
que estarán allí apoyando cada uno a su
selección